why would the powers that be want that
if what runs the economy is essentially
transactions yeah I don't understand
like a PhD fake doctor but essentially
we need transactions for the economy to
go and if everybody's staying in this is
the whole thing we're like the cure
can't be worse than the virus I don't
think that I think that the powers that
be are above the economy so I don't
think the powers would be our ever
economy dependent I think the powers
that be actually thrive in times like
this if you look like at any like rich
group of people they've made all their
money in times of tragedy not time this
is when rich people are lying and is
when the market is it like so they can't
wait for the [ __ ] to pop like you look
at these like rich rich rich families
yeah
they either marriage drug money or they
made it with war money buy war money I
mean they literally bet on the wars yeah
that's fair so if they see the [ __ ] hit
the fan they're like whoo we're about to
eat again baby I was waiting for this
[ __ ] to hit the fan now they eat again
and they have control I would say they
would look forward to a recession I
don't know because if people if there's
a second wave and [ __ ] not
going out I don't think it's a recession
I think it's a depression I think no
like no businesses are left yeah and I
don't know if they want to ride through
a depression to make their money I think
they'll ride through the recession but
the depression I don't even think it's
like the lives I think it's just like
it's too much time it's like I'm not
gonna see the isolated so unaffected
we're talking about like money that
doesn't go away we're not talking about
like millionaire rich we're like you're
a millionaire but then you lose your
million and then you're jumping out of
the building and Wall Street we're
talking about like generational wealth
where it's be effective in the smallest
way but you'll be able to bump up bump
that up by purchasing all this [ __ ] that
is gone broke anyway like you see
classism really being exhibited right
now cuz we'll talk about it and when it
hit I was like you know what I'm not
handing out I've got I'm good for a bit
Ike if this goes on for a bit I can live
I'm not saying I'm going up buying a new
car or a Harley but we can get by for a
little bit you know what I mean and then
you're at that level to where obviously
it's like okay we're not I don't kind of
[ __ ] sell everything I have but look
at on the lower levels people that
didn't have their first month of rent
and people that are hope
think that those rent rakes are given
and then it doesn't make sense because
you see it where people like you still
gotta pay rent but this guy that you pay
it to doesn't have to pay his mortgage
so you get to see how richer people make
money right away they're saving money on
the interest on the mortgage it's like
if you're rich you're making more money
through it and then the real rich people
this is money making time yeah because
when that market went from 29 down to 20
or 19 you don't think you're swooping in
buy and knowing it's gonna rebound to at
least 27 I'm gonna make a 30 or money
back there like snapping your fingers
I'm gonna [ __ ] this up a little bit
right but there's this family I'm sure
everybody's heard about the Rothschilds
right it does I don't we have to get
into conspiracy we'll just talk about
like factual [ __ ] right and there was a
time where this is before information
was passing quickly right this is before
internet before you know phone calls
that kind of stuff this is like people
were handing messages courier yeah
service right and I believe maybe World
War one does that make sense maybe maybe
it was war even prior to that I'm [ __ ]
up which war was point is it was thought
that England was going to lose that war
mmm-hmm right because that guy had such
sophisticated personal courier service
because his way of getting information
around was NASA he knew that they
actually won this battle before
everybody in England won hmm he propped
them up with what would be the
equivalent of nine hundred million
dollars today right right propped up
being investing essentially in England
he bought English debt at that time he
that he bought bonds essentially in
England now the market is [ __ ] the bed
because everyone in England thought that
they lost right so those bars are worth
what nothing yeah he gobbles them all up
knowing they won yeah no battle did he
prop him up thinking they would win down
the road he probably knows so that they
would okay and when everybody thought
that they lost yeah took advantage of
that loss right what I'm saying is
you'll see the same exact thing happened
and that's how big my you made 40
percent of your money yeah percent four
hundred million dollars in a [ __ ] day
[Applause]